foreign
[Music]
five minutes
I still see falling blocks in my dreams
it's poetry art and math all working in
magical synchronicities
perfect game Tetris Tetris Tetris Tetris
Tetris I don't get it
It's a combination of tetra Greek for
four and tennis tennis the Russian
inventor he likes tennis
this game isn't just addictive it stays
with you this is a once a lifetime
opportunity hey only 10 other people in
the world have seen what you're about to
see
it's called The Game Boy packaging with
Tetris can you get us the rights
the show view Union had worldwide rights
nothing gets out easily I'm gonna go to
Moscow you're walking into a country
they're still considers America enemy
Numero Uno okey dokey you sure you don't
have to talk to your wife about this
first pioneers have to bet the house to
win but not literally listen
have you ever heard our apartment this
quiet before
this is the inventor of Tetris your game
is brilliant I'm Gonna Make You A
Millionaire histologist have you ever
negotiated with the Soviets
we're here for Tetris
what do you say I don't speak Russian
s
do you know where your husband is what
the hell is going on the world is
changing and Soviet Union will not be
left behind you want to play with the
big boys this is how the world Works
where is my money this is insane we
can't protect you sometimes you gotta
forget
again
this is Criminal
the Soviet Union is about to implode
they're lying everybody's lying the
Cavalry is coming we don't have time I
have a plan
oh come on you guys are the kings of
Cliffhangers
foreign
[Music]